[Music]
here we have a quiet little motel when
in fact it has now become known as the
scene of the crime you have a vacancy
oh we have 12 vacancies
you know this is the first place it
looks like it's hiding from the world
i think that
we're all in our private traps
clamped in them
[Music]
and none of us can ever get out
is anyone at home oh that must be my
mother
if there's anything wrong
am i acting as if there's something
wrong she's not missing so much as she's
run away
what are you running away from she
looked like a wrong one to you
it's not as if she were a maniac
[Music]
she just goes
a little mad sometimes
why she wouldn't even have a fly
[Music]
you've got your toothbrush
do you have your deodorant yeah do you
have your cozy clothes got that
what
do they know i'm black
should they you might wanna you know mom
and dad my black boyfriend will be
coming up this weekend i just don't want
you to be shocked that he's a black man
i ain't never seen you like this before
bro meeting families taking road trips
back all bougie bad come back get your
damn pants up to your damn stomach
[Applause]
so you guys coming up from the city yeah
we're just heading up for the weekend
can i see your license please he wasn't
driving i didn't ask who was driving i
asked to see his id
call me dean and you hug me my man so
how long has this been going on this
thing
we hired georgina and walter to help
care for my parents
when they died i couldn't bear to let
him go
do you smoke in front of my daughter i'm
gonna quit she'd take care of that for
you how hypnosis
i'm good actually
are you ready for this
i'm back in the day
so look i go do my research
apparently a whole bunch of brothers
been missing in this suburb but it's
cool bro how you're not scared of this
man
couldn't see another brother around here
chris was just telling me how he felt
much more comfortable with my being here
you know sorry man
get out yo
[Applause]
bros we gotta go is everything okay
roast the keys
just get the keys i don't know where
they are rose
[Music]
everything to waste
if there's too many white people are
getting nervous
no
no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
the mine is a terrible thing to waste
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
that's a classic right here
what does i got five on it
it's about drugs it's not about drugs
it's a dope song don't do drugs get in
rhythm
[Music]
can't believe how big they've got do you
hear gabe got a
he's boat right he's not kidding hey i
think it's vodka clock oh yeah where's
jason
jason jason where were you i didn't know
if you were lost stick with me and i'll
keep you safe
[Music]
there's a family in our driveway it's
probably the neighbors
which i'll scare a family
hi can i help you
zara
put your shoes on if you want to get
crazy we can get crazy
[Music]
why are you people
it's us
they look exactly like us
they think like us
they know where we are
we need to move and keep moving
they won't stop until they kill us
and we kill them
[Music]
be careful
so
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're millionaires boys i'll share it
with all of you play in a few months
it'll be up in lights on broadway
[Music]
wild weird wonderful the stuff for which
movies were made
adventure to make you wonder if it's
true while your eyes convince you that
it is
truly the thrill of thrills
don't miss it this time
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
there is a creature alive today
who has survived millions of years of
evolution
without change
without passion
and without logic
it lives to kill
a mindless eating machine
it will attack
and devour
anything
it is as if god
created the devil
and gave him
jaws
[Music]
this is universal's extraordinary motion
picture version
of peter benchley's best-selling novel
jaws
i just found out
that a girl got killed here last week
and you knew it
you knew there was a shark out there
you knew it was dangerous but you let
people go swimming anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
it's all psychological you yell
barracuda
devices huh what you yell
shark we've got a panic on our hands on
the fourth of july is it true that most
people get attacked by sharks in three
feet of water about 10 feet from the
beach
yeah
what we are dealing with here is a
perfect engine uh
an eating machine we're not only gonna
have to close the beach we're gonna have
to hire somebody to kill the shark bad
fish
but i'll catch him and kill him
did you hear your father on the water
now this shark
swallow you home
you're gonna need a bigger boat
that's a 20-footer
25
three tons on them
[Music]
don't wait for me now
[Music]
[Music]
hurry
[Music]
none of man's fantasies of evil and
compare with the reality
of jaws
[Music]
roy scheider
robert shaw
richard dreyfuss
jaws
[Music]
see it
before you go swimming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who are we if we can't protect them
we have to protect them
[Applause]
adrian
was a sociopath he said that i could
never leave him he controlled how i
looked and what i wore
then i was
controlling when i left the house
and eventually what i thought
i'm sorry i can't take you with me i'm
not gonna leave
are you okay
what happened to him
adrian's dead
listen
you're getting your freedom back okay
he said that wherever i went he would
find me
walk right up to me and i wouldn't be
able to see him adrian is dead he's not
dead he has figured out a way to be
invisible
okay he's sitting in that chair
uh
[Music]
where are you
show yourself
surprise
[Music]
let me help you
you can't help me
surprise
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
he's got it
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you